s'il est une cause qui peut nous
rassembler par-delà l'éclivage politique
je crois profondément que c'est la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire ce fléo
absolument insupportable qui fait que
des élèves vont à l'école la boule au
ventre et parfois se donnent la mort
parce qu'ils subissent les brimades les
insultes les coups et je vous remercie
du caractère très constructif de votre
question et je vous confirme que pour
lutter contre ce fléo nous avons besoin
de toutes les bonnes idées et que le
groupe LR du Sénat apporta ces dernières
années des idées madame ci la fait et
d'autres et que ça nous inspire
évidemment dans notre action vous m'avez
posé trois questions très concrètes la
première sur la formation oui nous
généralisons le programme phare qui fait
que dans chaque établissement scolaire
vous devez avoir au moins 5 adultes
formés avec une vraie formation sur la
lutte contre le harcèlement des
enseignants des personnels de vie
scolaire d'autres personnels aussi on
s'est rendu compte par exemple que
former des agents de la cantine c'était
très utile parce qu'il voi beaucoup de
choses et qu'ils peuvent aussi détecter
et signaler deuxième chose sur le
questionnaire effectivement demain est
une journée importante chaque année il y
a la journée de lutte contre le
harcèlement les années précédentes
c'était autour d'un tiers des
établissements qui organisaient une
action cette année j'ai décidé que tous
les établissements scolaires devront le
faire et pour vous répondre très
concrètement les 2 heures banalisées ne
sont absolument pas une option ça me
permet de le rappeler que d'avoir cette
question la classe doit s'arrêter
pendant 2h dans tous les établissements
scolaires pour un débat sur le
harcèlement et ce questionnaire
d'autoévaluation que nous avons rédigé
avec Marcelle ruffau Nicole Katheline
Éric de Barbieux trè question sur le
changement de règle je l'ai dit dès cet
été après ma nomination c'est au
harceleurs de quitter l'établissement et
non plus au harceler et oui cette règle
s'applique je vous donne un exemple à
montmarsan un lycéen fait l'objet de
harcèlement depuis la rentrée scolaire
le 9 octobre il le signale au chef
d'établissement qui l'accompagne dans le
dépôt d'une plainte une semaine plus
tard les trois élèves harceleurs âgés de
15 et 16 ans sont interpellés par les
forces de police en garde à vue ils
passeront devant le juge des enfants le
15 novembre et entre-temps ils ont été
exclus de l'établissement ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de jeunes harceleurs
qui ont été exclus de leur établissement
depuis que j'ai pris cette décision la
peur est en train de changer de camp la
honte est en train de changer de camp
évidemment il y a encore du travail
parce que ça ne s'applique pas encore
partout mais vous pouvez compter sur ma
mobilisation comme je sais pouvoir
compter sur la vôtre pour
avancer